cette présentation quelque peu aride mes
chers collègues vise à montrer que même
si le Sénat devra naturellement avoir
ses propres marqueurs nous ne
disposerons que de fort peu de marge de
manœuvre pour adopter des mesures
généreuses en recette comme en dépense
les quelques marges existantes ont déjà
été utilisées il ne serait pas
responsable de notre part de voter une
réforme qui suscite tendez moi dans le
pays si nous ne rétablissons pas
véritablement la trajectoire budgétaire
de notre système de retraite
la vraie générosité la vraie générosité
pour les générations futures consiste à
leur léguer un système de retraite
financièrement solide et dans lequel
elles peuvent avoir confiance
[Musique]